and Russia is being accused of beheading
a captured Ukrainian Soldier the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
said this act would not be forgotten or
forgiven we have two correspondents on
the story dorsa jabaris and Moscow will
speak to her in just a moment but first
let's bring in Jonah Hall uh joining us
from Keith to tell us what more we're
learning about this alleged incident
Jonah and whether the video has been
independently verified
but we've grown used in the last 14
months or so haven't we to seeing pretty
gruesome footage of War but this
particular incident makes a very Grim
viewing indeed and for that reason we're
obviously not able to broadcast it there
are two videos in fact that emerged
overnight one showing uh purporting to
show two Ukrainian uh military corpses
beheaded the second video is far more
graphic it purports to show a Russian
soldier torturing and then beheading a
Ukrainian prisoner of war and there are
signs in the video that the Ukrainian uh
may have been alive when the beheading
process begins uh importantly it is
impossible to independently verify this
video equally it is impossible to
independently verify its context the
units involved where it happened or when
it happened although it's been pointed
out that the foliage in the surroundings
in the video particularly Lush and green
suggests that this was taken at the very
least well before the start of winter
last year it's gained a lot of traction
on social media and has generated some
significant comment here in Ukraine uh
dimitro culeba the foreign minister
likening Russia as a result of this
video to Islamic State and of course
president zielinski releasing a
statement of his own calling on world
leaders to react he said Don't expect
this to be forgotten by us we are not
going to forget here's what he had to
say
there's something that no one in the
world can ignore how easily these beasts
kill this video the execution of a
Ukrainian captive the world must see it
this is a video of Russia as it is the
kind of creatures they are there are no
people for them a son a brother a
husband Someone's Child this is video of
Russia trying to make this a new Norm
such a habit of destroying life so
that's the comment from zelenski let's
bring in dorsa Jabari who's joining us
from Moscow to find out whether there
has been any reaction from the Kremlin
dorsa to this
yes we just heard from the Kremlin
spokesperson Dimitri peskov a short
while ago and he had a brief statement
on this video he said that first it
needs to be verified and that it is
appalling and rather disturbing footage
that it shows we haven't heard from any
other high-ranking officials in the
country so far about this video that's
circulating but according to Dmitry
peskov it first needs to be verified and
they also the Kremlin agrees that it is
quite disturbing I think they're going
to have to wait and see down the line
how they can react once and if the
footage is verified yeah okay dorisa
you'll keep us across the story but let
me ask you about another development
from Russia and we understand that
Parliament is is due to discuss new
conscription legislation what's that
about
well this is a bill that was first
introduced in February February 22nd to
be exact just before the war broke out
of 2022 in the state Duma that is the
lower house of parliament in this
country where it proposed some changes
to the mandatory military service that
men in Russia between the ages of 18 and
27 have to go through they have a
one-year military service that is
mandatory the bill that was passed in
its third and final reading in the Duma
house on Tuesday basically states that
currently the process is that men are
received in a letter from the military
via posts that they need to report for
Duty and they need to go to an
enlistment recruitment office of the
military they have a window of 20 days
once the letter is received now when the
defense Ministry issues these letters it
takes them up to seven days to verify
that it's been received by the person
they sent it out to now the changes they
propose is that this is going to become
a digital system and according to the
Kremlin it is because it was the
enlistment process was such a chaotic
mess over the past few months that they
decided to move to a digital system now
that means as soon as a person's details
are uploaded on the system they have uh
they will be considered served they will
have 20 days from that date that their
up the details are uploaded to report to
a facility to report for Duty and also
immediately they will not be allowed to
leave the country that is one of the
main issues
that means it becomes much more
difficult for men in this country to
dodge the military service that they
have to go through and if they don't
report within that time frame then there
is a number of restrictions that will be
placed on them that will make life very
difficult for them not only they won't
be able to leave the country they will
not be allowed to rent any property they
will not be allowed to register any
businesses so really they're trying to
find all kinds of ways to ensure that
the system is a smooth one okay thank
you so much Dorsey Jabari reporting from
Moscow